- Well, your dad is of course, Arnold.
Does he ever use...
This as a real question.
Does he ever use any of
his like iconic lines
like just casually?
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- 'Cause we all wanna know.
- Everybody asks that.
They're like, "Does
your dad like always say
like his one-liners," and
I'm like, "All the time."
- Like, I hope that every
time he exits a room,
he says, "I'll be back."
- He does.
He'll turn back, and be
like, "I'll be back."
I'll be like, "Dad,
really? Like, come on."
- You're over it but we think it's funny.
- I know.
Other people do, but
sometimes, like, a little kid,
like a six-year-old, the dad
will kind of shove the kid
to go get an autograph
from my dad or something.
The kid probably has no idea who my dad is
and goes up and like asks for something
and my dad will just like scream
one of the one-liners at him.
And the kid's like, "What?
(Kelly laughing)
"I don't know, I don't know what that is."
- It's a test. You have
to earn the autograph.
You have to know the film.
That's actually a good idea.